he is basically saying here the plan was  justified the plan was justified because  a lot of americans never believed or  don't believe or still don't believe or  were convinced that joe biden didn't  actually win the election the whole  point here was to expose this and to  expose it early and to expose it from uh  day one so that is steve bannon um not  denying that saying yeah we we were  justified in organizing that rally the  rally which eventually led of course to  the uh to the riots and by the way  consider the double standard right  there's the double standard of  we absolutely had to plan that rally  because joe biden either stole the  election or was already setting us up  for a disaster or whatever and at the  same time the rioters were were really  antifa they were they weren't really  trumpists but we did plan we planned the  rally but the rioters were fake and we  were justified in one but we had  absolutely nothing to do with the other  come on guys come on